papapapa françois joly dépêchez vous ils
ne sont pas là ça alors je suis sûr que
c'est de ce paresseux sont encore en
train de dormir
c'est incroyable je vais finir par me
mettre en colère
bonjour vous savez je suis furieux nous
devons aller faire une grande promenade
en bateau françois julie et moi ils ne
sont pas là ils ne sont pas là je vais
finir par me mettre en colère c'est nous
devions me faire un pique nique en mer
alors ici si nous partons pas tout de
suite le bateau ça on ira sans nous bon
je vais mettre ma bouée avec les autres
objets et je vais aller les chercher
sinon nous allons finir par le rater ce
bateau bon à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
casimir casimir
ouais tu tiens c'est curieux je croyais
qu'ils nous attendaient ici
[Musique]
julie fait sentir mais gérer nettement
mieux si j'avais dormi un peu à kiel dit
julie casimir est venu me réveiller plus
de 10 fois cette nuit pour me demander
l'heure qu'il est ils avaient peur
d'être en retard pour le départ du petit
label ne te plains pas ça a été bien
pire pour moi parce que quand il allait
te voir il passait par chez moi pour me
dire de me préparer ce que je ne faisais
pas et en revenant il me réveillait à
nouveau pour me dire gentiment que ça
n'était pas encore l'heure à l'aller et
au retour
oh là là mais la majorité a réveillé
deux fois plus que moi au combat pour
julie tu veux un peu de cas qu être au
oui oui c'est ça va me réveiller enfin
j'espère en tout cas les plus fatigués
des 3c doit être lui parce qu'il n'a pas
fermé l'oeil de la nuit
je sais je sais que tu sais mais je lui
ai dit que c'était ridicule qui ferait
mieux de dormir dormir je veux dormir
pour être en pleine forme et le
lendemain matin profiter au maximum de
sa promenade en mer que telle était si
content à l'idée d'aller pique-niquer en
mer je suis bien julie m'enfin suis
quand même pas une raison pour pour
avoir peur dès le milieu de la nuit des
temps d'arrêt et réveiller la moitié de
l'île aux enfants
moi je connais beaucoup d'enfants qui
sont comme ça des scores mais julie mais
qu'est-ce que ça
ce doit être ce que casimir voulait
emporter sur le bateau bon la vidéo mais
ça m'a l'air d'en avoir besoin d'un
sérieux truies en f
laissons les enfants venez vite nous
avons déjà deux jours les enfants voilà
ce qui se passe casimir a rassemblé tous
ces objets et il veut les emporter sur
son bateau mais moi je crois qu'il a
fait quelques erreurs
il est bien aidé commençons par ceux ci
qu'est ce que c'est ouais il peut
l'emporter sur son bateau wii la wii je
l'aimais par ici ceux ci qu'est ce que
c'est paire de patins à glace
il peut s'en servir sur son bateau mais
non évidemment ceux ci excuse moi je
t'ai fait mal non qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une scène pour monter à cheval
il en aura besoin sur son bateau kazim
lma
c'est une paire de skis oui non sauvette
non parce que ça se sache se sont pas
les skis nautiques ce sont des skis
glisser sur la neige
ensuite qu'est ce que c'est une boîte en
osier donc c'est un thani pour mettre
les crabes et les poissons donc casimir
peut effectivement on l'emporté sur son
bateau et ceci malgré le baril a plongé
oui alors il peut l'emporter oui hein
ceux-ci casques de motards qui ne peut
on parle
quel accord c'est un rouleau de cordage
casimir peut s'en servir
à ton avis oui oui je veut s'en servir
pour amarrer son bateau quand ils
arrivent au port à sac de voyage de
marne donc je vous remercie beaucoup les
enfants à les jouer maintenant
je les leur passé casimir n'est toujours
pas là alors c'est lui qui va nous
mettre en retard je ne vois pas du tout
will a pu passer les émirs casimir au
kazim kazim kazim kazim est en soi oui
qu'est parti au bas saint laurent
mais il s'est endormi à force de marcher
toute la nuit il devait être mort de
fatigue 18 mesures victoire à les cadets
miravet 3 voyons casimir nous allons
être en retard tu vas raté ta belle
promenade en bateau mouche
le pitch
casimir
[Musique]